هذه هي HMS alderia ، إنها
سفينة حربية سعودية على وشك المغادرة من هنا
في جدة في مواجهة الملك للقاعدة البحرية
إلى بورتسودان ، تستغرق الرحلة من 10 إلى 12 ساعة
عبر البحر الأحمر لإجلاء
المزيد من الأشخاص من السودان ، وهذه واحدة من
الجيش السعودي ولكن هناك أيضًا
سفن تجارية تقوم بنفس الشيء على
وشك القدوم إلى الميناء هنا في
جدة وحتى الآن يقول السعوديون أنه
خارج العملية ، تم إجلاء حوالي 3000 شخص
من Fort Sudan
فقط حوالي 100 من  كانوا
مواطنين سعوديين جاءوا من ثمانية إلى
دول مختلفة بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة والمملكة
المتحدة وأستراليا وكندا وكينيا ودول
من جميع أنحاء العالم المملكة العربية السعودية هي
لاعب دبلوماسي رئيسي في السودان وهي
جزء مما يسمى الرباعية التي
تضم الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
والإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لذلك عندما يأتي هؤلاء الأشخاص إلى
هنا ، تلقوا تهجينًا من هناك
بأنهم قدموا طعامًا ويرسلون إلى
الفنادق عند الضرورة حتى يتمكنوا من
ترتيب ترتيبات السفر النهائية أو
أي شيء آخر يذهبون إليه ،
أصبح هذا سريعًا أحد  أكبر
جهود إجلاء دولية منذ
آخر مرة في العالم ، لذلك
كان شيء من هذا القبيل عندما استولت طالبان على
أفغانستان ومع استمرار الصراع
في السودان أصبح أمرًا
بالغ الأهمية لإخراج الكثير من الناس من
الصراع في السودان Laramie Dover CNN
Jetta